at least 13 people have died after a
magnitude 6.5 earthquake struck Northern
Afghanistan and parts of Pakistan the
epicenter was in the Hindu Kush
mountains near the northern Afghan
province of barakshan people in Kabul
were Outdoors when the Quake hit because
they were celebrating the Persian New
Year many chose to spend the night
outdoors at least nine people died in
Pakistan where hospitals were placed on
high alert we're going to go live to
Assad Bank who's joining us now from
Lahore we just saw some of the pictures
there during the earthquake you've felt
the earthquake where you are what's it
been like
well yes we did feel the earthquake we
were in hotel rooms and the hotel began
to shake so we made our way outside and
we met with many people out on the
streets here in Lahore many people
saying that they didn't feel safe
especially on considering recent events
in Turkey so people were out on the
streets and later images immersed of
people across the country not only here
but in Islamabad but even bashawar
around 530 kilometers away out on the
streets filming they're building some
with cracks in those buildings but
generally there hasn't really been that
much destruction
I mentioned before that there were at
least 13 people said I've been confirmed
as having died do we have any more
reports on casualties and and people who
might have been killed
so around Northwest of where we are here
in Lahore in Hebron now we've heard that
at least 150 people have been injured
there and nine people died when some
buildings collapsed other people were
injured from falling wolves and so forth
so the injuries haven't been that much
but what we have heard is that there
have been landslides that have cut off
roads and also in gilgit in Pakistan
authorities say that those roads that
those landslides have caused those roads
to be cut off so it will take some time
to get to some of those remote Villages
now we've also heard from Afghanistan
with that earthquake originated and
we've heard that some of those Villages
are very remote with no phone or
internet connection so it will take some
time to get access to those areas to
really get a real idea to in terms of
the extent of the damage that's this
this earthquake has caused we can see
it's the the traffic on the streets
behind you what is the mood there now I
mean I've only been through a very minor
earthquake and that was unsettling
enough what's it like
well this morning it seems like business
as usual but when you speak to people
here they have been uh on social media
and even before this earthquake there
had been some predictions that this
region would face the earthquake so that
was on people's minds but also if you
take into account the events of turkey
and people have seen the destruction
there there was this considerable fear
amongst people even now when you speak
to them but also there was an earthquake
back in 2005 in Pakistani administered
Kashmir where around 87 000 people died
and that's still at the Forefront of
people's minds so there is this sense of
fear is this a one-off will there be
aftershocks will there be further
earthquakes so when you speak to people
they are scared but even last night in
some areas there were some considerable
Panic after that earthquake but right
here in Lahore right now in Lahore it is
business as usual this morning but
question still remain in terms of people
wondering if there are more to follow I
said thank you very much indeed that's
our setback joining us from Lahore